please welcome my friend joel mchale
[Applause]
oh thank you spare bedroom thank you
this is so nice of you drew you look
amazing and you're dressed kind of like
post st
patrick's day um cheek that's exactly
right
happy post saint patrick's day yeah are
you irish
oh yeah um you know it's been a minute
since we've seen each other
and i was giggling with delight
at you and your teenage boys and
i just was so excited that your boys
like did they get the funny gene
i heard they're sarcastic edward and
isaac
oh yeah uh i might when they were born
when the first one was born now he's 16
my dad who i gave endless amounts
of crap to uh he was just like
you are in for it and uh
and he wasn't joking so like they'll
they'll watch
like community thank you uh they'll
watch community and be like
hey dad we really like that episode
except for your acting it was terrible
and i'm back okay great and then they'll
they'll you know i'll just be like hey
guys dinner's ready and then my kids
will go oh okay dad
yeah what are they or
i don't you might experience this
they'll be in their bedroom like playing
a video game or on a chat call or i
don't know what they're doing
but i'll come in and they'll just go
what
and i'll be like what did what do you
mean what
this is my house i paid for it olive
always pulls that this is my house i'm
like i don't think so because i don't
remember
seeing your name on the last payment
she's eight
almost nine going on like 15. it's
insane i have
full blown teenage problems with her i
have
like my 16 year old would be like hey
dad when do you think you'll be relevant
again
oh my god what's happening joel oliver
was mad at me the other night and her
sister was like no but our mom
is like great and she goes she's just
some entertainer
oh yeah that's
that's when you should go into the
gladiator speech and be like
am i here are you entertained uh that is
yeah i will sometimes just turn off the
lights and go
oh look who pays for that me and then
again
i'll be like you're warm you've been
warned it's just when they start driving
cars i don't know what's going to happen
i i i feel i fear for the city of los
angeles
i know i can't believe anyone let me
have a driver's license at 16. i'm sad
to say
i got taken away from me right away like
i didn't last a year before i got that
thing revoked
uh my what did you do several moving
violations
like within the first year and they just
swiped it away
and it was gone for like a year or two
and i went from feeling
so cool in my jeep to
right back to can i get a ride that
yeah i so my brothers
one is 21 months younger and the other
one is 26 months
older so we were dry it was like
uh you know 15 with a permit 17 driving
and 19.
we totaled four cars
two and a half years and my dad was like
i'm gonna have a tick i'm gonna have a
tremor because of you guys
and we were pushing cars off the side of
the road that we accidentally ran into
stuff
and i i don't know how we survived
that's i think that's the
point of i was told that like oh you
have a boy your job is to keep them
alive until they leave the house
because they will find a way to just
jump stuff
and jump off railings and yeah so yeah
i'm i'm i have a tick now
well you know i love that you know
you and your wife have been together for
25 years
is that right uh we will be married 25
years in july
and we were so 27 years together and
i don't know why drew but she has agreed
to be with me for all these years uh she
has tolerated so much
uh she is she's you know she does the
classic like yes i have i have two boys
and an infant and the infant's name is
joel uh so
i'm very very lucky and uh yeah i
i hope we i hope we can be together for
another 27.
gosh i just love that you guys have been
together 27 years and want to be
together another 27
any tips for a good marriage
uh well uh she doesn't she laughs at
about
five percent of my jokes
constant like me trying to get her to
laugh so if i tell her a joke she'll go
oh yeah a material there joel
so you're getting it from all ends and
i'll be like i'm a professional
uh i would say the best advice i ever
got
for a happy marriage is
happy wife happy life and uh if she's
happy
i'm happy everyone's happy listen humor
doesn't hurt
and you have a new movie which
ironically is called
happily um about a married couple
but it's so apparently crazy
and intense and delectable we couldn't
show a clip
what is up with that uh yeah this movie
is about a
couple that has been married for 14
years and they are
very amorous they uh they still
are as frisky as they were when they got
married
and all their friends hate them for it
so
and then it gets pretty crazy so it's
like a
it's like an episode of the twilight
zone with just a lot of
a lot of sex well i'm really glad that
you brought it with this movie and i'm
so excited and it just seems so
delicious and so fun and listen we could
all use
a little you know inspo to keep it
frisky
and fun so i just love the tone of this
movie
putting out there i think it's going to
be very well embraced and
i do feel like if someone said you can
watch this movie about a couple having
problems
or you can watch this cup well like get
it on and have a blast with a fun twist
at the end there's no question which one
i'm picking
i'm picking the good couple every single
time that was a lot of what victor
wanted with santa clarita diet he said i
don't want to watch this couple fight
i'm not interested in that people have
to do that you know in life let's look
at a couple that
finds their way out of things and is
successful and there's a lightness there
uh i will say on the santa clarita diet
uh set and on blended
like the crew adored you which is a
very good sign just so you know folks
that when the crew doesn't like an actor
you
you can feel it and it's not a fun place
and when they do like an actor it's a
playground so
yeah uh that that is at the i always go
like at the end of
you people you know they do work they do
stuff but at the end of the
day at the end of your life you're like
you made a bunch of people happy for a
lot of hours of their life like
congratulations drew barrymore well
thank you joe mike
for saying that you did and i'm going to
turn it right back on you
and say all the stuff you've put out
into the world has been
fun and wonderful
[Music]